jean michel est un jeune agriculteur
maraîcher à saint louis
quand on est agriculteur on laisse sept
jours sur sept
un travail éprouvant qui nécessite une
véritable passion c'est le cas de jean
michel
il aime ce qu'il fait malheureusement
ces dernières années le sud de l'île a
subi des périodes de sécheresse
régulière un manque d'eau qui complique
terriblement le travail et met en danger
son activité sans eau pas de culture
possible et sans soutien
jean-michel ne pourrait même plus
exercer aujourd'hui si vraiment c'est
une coupure s'est pas trop trop trop
grave nous on sera coupée une journée et
pas plus mais sinon si c'est pas pour
cilaos le bras de la plaine y ait pas de
bain on est comme tout le monde on a des
pompages sur le plateau du goal qui
permet justement quand le brésil a aussi
le bras de la plaine et yappa douce est
saturé un bout on a l'obligation pense
qu'on a deux ou trois dieux station de
pompage dans dans les bacs qui nous aide
nous aidera à maresché d'avoir l'autre
les jours jean michel reçoit un soutien
technique pendant les périodes de crise
il a bénéficié des aides pour acheminer
l'eau jusqu'à son exploitation est
installé un système de goutte-à-goutte
les normes sont très exigeantes et sans
aide son système d'irrigation n'aurait
pas pu être achevée car trop coûteux
pour lui on les aime
on peut pas se sentir comme je vous dis
si on est installé depuis longtemps on a
la trieuse aurait depuis longtemps on
peut sentir
mais quand on est jeune c'est très
difficile sont au conseil général
aujourd'hui est très très difficile pour
remédier aux problèmes récurrents que
rencontre jean-michel et l'ensemble des
agriculteurs du sud depuis plusieurs
années le département a lancé un gros
chantier pour créer une interconnexion
entre le bras de la plaine et celui de
cilaos améliorer l'acheminement de l'eau
dans toutes les régions de l'île un
engagement du conseil général depuis des
décennies des travaux lourds et coûteux
mais nécessaire pour que la population
réunionnaise sans exception puissent
recevoir son lot toute l'année sans
coupure sans même y penser
les besoins sont partout qu'on soit
particuliers agriculteurs organismes
privés ou publics
l'eau c'est la vie l'eau est un facteur
primordial de l'économie à la réunion et
dans les années à venir
l'enjeu de l'eau sa quantité sa qualité
seront des thèmes majeurs
le conseil général investit depuis des
années dans des infrastructures
permettant d'équilibrer les ressources
partout dans l'île objectif permettre à
tous les réunionnais d'est en ouest du
nord au sud de ne jamais manquer de cet
élément essentiel de leur quotidien
l'eau